major breaking story okay we've been
silent on Russia for a while huge news
on Russia yesterday the looming
indictment of former Trump campaign
Chairman Paul Manafort we found out
about wiretaps we found out about so
much other stuff yesterday and we have
even more news today and it relates to
finances once again and to remind you
yesterday I made clear it is becoming
more and more obvious that the Trump
Russia investigation is going in the
direction under the leadership of robert
muller the special prosecutor of looking
at financial crimes a number of
money-laundering prosecutors prosecutors
expert in money-laundering crimes have
been hired and it's becoming a follow
the money thing so the big news broken
by reuters yesterday and sort of built
upon by CNN later reuters released
yesterday that they spoke to two people
familiar with the situation who say
Donald Trump is using money that has
been donated to his reelection campaign
and money donated to the RNC to pay his
lawyers representing him in the Russia
collusion investigation Reuters went
public with that and then CNN followed
up and said hey we found out that the
RNC in August paid two hundred and
thirty thousand dollars to cover some of
Donald Trump's personal legal fees this
now goes beyond debating the merits of
Trump Russia collusion collusion or
debating whether Trump Russia is worth
talking about this should be triggering
a bipartisan reaction what's the law on
this right election law does allow the
use of private campaign funds to pay for
legal bills that arise from being a
candidate what does that mean right the
controversy here is that usually when
you say well it's okay to use donations
to cover legal fees that arise from
being a candidate its disputes over
ballot access in an election so donated
funds are used to pay for that or there
are questions about compliance during an
election so donated money is used to pay
for those legal bills this is the first
time that a president would be using or
is using campaign funds donated funds
and Republican Party funds
to pay for the cost of lawyers for a
criminal investigation particularly one
that started because of suspected
collusion with a foreign power once
again we are in uncharted legal
territory and maybe this is just step
one that I'm fixated on but if Donald
Trump really is a multi billionaire why
would he even have to do this I mean a
few hundred thousand dollars to him
would just be peanuts that's right so
there's the legal or sort of moral gray
area of well if you do a legal stuff
during a campaign then you can say any
legal fees related to that are related
directly to me being a candidate but
here we actually have an investigation
that's extending beyond just what took
place during the campaign it relates to
money laundering and other possible
financial crimes from before Donald
Trump was officially a candidate but how
do you justify if you are a billionaire
needing to use donated money to cover
your legal expenses it's unconscionable
what is going on and we found out that
Michael Flynn who is not nearly as rich
as Trump is but still is worth about
seven million dollars yeah he's setting
up a legal defense fund with the help of
his family - yes you don't have to raise
it from the public you've got that money
you can donate on PayPal to michael
Flynn's legal defense fund and you can
find the link on his Twitter account I
mean that that's where we are we talked
about that yesterday former national
security adviser is asking for PayPal
donations on Twitter to cover legal
expenses for possible criminal activity
involving foreign powers so the let me
remind you of something else
the day after Donald Trump was
inaugurated I mentioned to you hey
Donald Trump has filed for re-election
already Trump is already formally
running for re-election in 2020 why one
reason he probably did that was that it
allows him to more easily keep raising
money and it also offers him some
protections from how special interest
groups can advertise against him because
he's an active candidate of an election
but there might be another reason right
the legal defense stuff this is part of
the boon for Trump of already being a
candidate for president for 2020 now you
might say David everybody does this
crooked Hillary did the same thing well
actually no Hillary Clinton paid million
of dollars to lawyers at Perkins coal
for handling routine legal issues her
campaign made no payments to the
Washington law firm Williams and
Connelly that represented her in the
private email server probe so this is
the opposite of what so-called crooked
Hillary did and if you're a Republican
donor if you're one of these big donors
and you donated to trump and you donate
it to the RNC and you find out they're
using the money for Trump's legal
defense from for from possible collusion
with a foreign power but also possibly
involving crimes that he committed
before he was even President of the
United States or candidate and you end
up not getting that big tax break he
promised will they be upset or will the
cognitive dissonance continue I
genuinely have no idea it's backwards
right it's Trump who should be paying
for the legal defenses of all the people
that he dragged into this rather than
Republican donors paying for Trump's
legal defense and I can't imagine that
there's too much in that account to
because if you're one of these
Republican donors are you really happy
with the return on investment that
you've gotten from Donald Trump and then
even if you talk about individual voters
what policies are you happy that he's
passed thus far and his presidency that
make you want to contribute again yeah I
don't know I don't know that that's uh
yeah I think we should be glad that a
lot of these major policy proposals that
Trump mentioned without really knowing
much about them during the campaign
haven't happened we should be glad about
that because a lot of them are horrible
but why would anybody be wrote donating
to the reelection campaign at this point
it doesn't make sense and there's a
strategic element that I want to mention
here which is important as well if
you're a Democrat and you know that the
RNC and Trump's re-election are paying
legal fees for Trump isn't it now
directly in your interest to create as
much bureaucratic red tape as possible
that will result in more Trump and
Republican money going to Trump's
lawyers the RNC has come out and said
hey listen this is not going to affect
how much money is available for other
candidates to be reelected in 2018 or
whatever at a certain point if the RNC
and Trump's re-election continue to be
bled for cash for Trump's lawyers it
can't be good for the reelection chances
of candidates in 2018 so I see this is
an in
Senta for Democrats to say let's make it
as difficult as possible for Donald
Trump to stop spending money on legal
defense funds I think it's something for
Democrats to consider today's program is
made possible in part by Blue Sky binary
forex trading major major space millions
of traders trading Forex around the
world 80% of them lose money you need to
understand basic proper money management
rules you need to understand how to
avoid getting emotional in your trading
you need to have the appropriate base of
knowledge for forex trading and blue sky
binaries education course provides
exactly that blue sky binary is a
leading financial education and tech
company they focus on FX and they've got
senior traders with real trading
experience offering a structured and
self-paced course and that includes
video on-demand it includes online tests
one-to-one education sessions access to
their community of traders to exchange
knowledge and experience and my viewers
and listeners can register right now at
Blue Sky binary.com slash David to get a
one-week free trial which includes not
only access to their platform and
training materials but also a session
with a senior trader to get you up to
speed on the basics of forex trading
continue as long as you want for $99.99
a month after that stop cancel resume as
you wish you can get the one-week free
trial at blue sky binary.com / David